ah the basic building blocks of all
living things
cells
these incredible packages of organelles
and subcellular components carry out a
variety of functions in the body
like taking in nutrients
converting them into energy
and working with other cells to produce
things that the body needs
each cell is essentially like its own
little mini factory
with complex processes occurring within
the cell to carry out specific functions
okay so when we zoom into the cell to
figure out how exactly these cell
processes are carried out one of the
star players is a class of biological
macromolecules known as
proteins
proteins carry out many incredibly
important tasks in the cell such as
providing structural support
aiding in chemical reactions
and even building or repairing the cell
we can imagine proteins as a chain of
amino acids kind of think of them as
like beads on a bracelet
that fold and twist
into distinct three dimensional shapes
the structure of a protein
along with
the chemical properties of its amino
acid evidently determine its function
does it form a round globular sphere
that can attach and interact with other
compounds or does it twist into long and
narrow strands that can provide
structural support
the huge variety of structures that
proteins can take on leads to the wide
range of cellular functions that they
can carry out
okay so now that we've talked about
proteins let's zoom back out to analyze
how different types of cells come
together to carry out a variety of
functions in an organism
this is where cell specialization comes
into play
which is the process
by which a cell takes on a specific
structure and function
so to better help understand this
concept let's consider a movie theater
analogy where the movie theater is your
body
there is the cashier that handles all
the money
the snack vendor who handles out popcorn
and snacks
and even the ticket operator who directs
you to the proper screenings
in this analogy each person has their
own distinct functions and what they
handle like money or popcorn or tickets
in a similar way the body is also
composed of specialized cells with
unique roles
such as
red blood cells that carry oxygen in the
blood
muscle cells
that contract and relax
or even nerve cells
that carry signaling messages throughout
the body
now remember how i told you about
proteins before
well cell specialization is largely
based on which proteins
are present or absent in the cell
it is a cell's unique combination
of proteins that determine which
functions can be carried out
but no cell works alone because teamwork
makes the dream work
groups of specialized cells
that carry out specific functions for
the organism are organized into tissues
looking back at our movie theater
analogy
there are multiple people within each
department that work together to help
the theater function efficiently
similarly our specialized cells work
together as tissues to help the organism
function
the red blood cells make up the blood
a connective tissue that moves important
substances throughout the body
the muscle cells help make up muscle
tissue
which helps the body move and neurons or
nerve cells make up nervous tissue
that helps the organism process
information
so what are the key takeaways about cell
specialization
number one
cells are the fundamental unit of life
they're the smallest structural and
functional unit of an organism
number two proteins help carry out cell
processes
number three specialized cells carry out
specific functions in an organism think
of the movie theater analogy where each
person has its own specific role
and number four groups of specialized
cells come together as tissues to carry
out one or more specific functions for
the organism